that's alright mr. Donnell I took the
liberty of telling the boys to go ahead
that's alright well what'd you come til
I want to change your song sure sure
ladies gentlemen welcome to another evening
hey ain't that good fondly now we're over there
in the white fish just getting out of a car
wait wait don't be a fool put that gun away
please you must give me a chance to explain
we better beat it before the cops show up
we don't want to get mixed up no killing
well come on you guys don't keep me waiting stop
clowning around where is she where is Ruth she's
gone Buchi oh you mean who's left town huh oh I
get it she's sore at me we had a little argument
and then she left town uh-huh but don't worry
I know my roof better than anybody else she'll
be back it's worse than that boss what do
you mean worse Annette hey come down here
you guys now what are you guys holding back
from me what's the matter she's dead what did
you say she's dead we was waiting for her when
you told us and when she showed up and she got
out of the car all of a sudden someone that go
with a handful of clouds whoa who did a woman
she fired four slugs and no one that made her
get away before we could do anything about it
would you know that woman again of you sorry sure
sure boss sure sure boss sure through this dinner
gee I never figured it that way and on my prayers
put a turtle doe and tell the cock-eyed world oh
hey do you know any cowboy songs happy gotta
go for that Calcutta thrown in ha PT I love
it you know happy I'd go right now on join
the June force if I had the train parallel
West what are you talking about the games boys
are dead dead they are not dead why I just saw
them in a motion picture the James boys yeah by
George you're right I saw it myself there goes
that bloomin charley horse again I just have
so much trouble with this thing I need more
yeah 10 minutes off this will fix it right
up boy saying you better get out of here and
deliver them papers they should have bought on
the street long time ago fine how's everything
going boy circulation man just was another
time how many issues so far that's colomac 5000
hey-ya people what's this what's this ad here
I'll buy your life if you're interested apply
Thursday alhambra arms ask a Darnell that same
kind of straight down the price sure does say
you don't think I could have made a mistake
in setting up that type and spent white for
the net will do yeah oh yeah then we'll gave it
to you oh I took the end myself a swell-looking
guy blows in here no team asked me how much the
ads gonna call but shells a double sawbuck in
my head oh all right just a minute I thought
it based I might have smoked it haha that's
well just well it says what I need for the
Robbins family let's see now the oldest kid
need shoes the youngest medicines and the rest
of them a flock of groceries always thank you
the other guy out there I got a great kick
out of it too happy that's all there is to
life if you can't help the other fella when
he's down how can you be right with yourself
I'll buy your life November arms lay down the
hell that has a familiar ring no fool yeah I've
got it he's the author of the famous captain
Cambridge novels what's their mystery stories
oh hello supermarket well this is Breen the
friend in need say listen will you send over
to the Robbins family another find out a basket
of groceries yeah yeah same as last time Thanks
oh yes sir ice water plenty of ice head
or how do you do miss how do you do mr.
slowest mr. Darnell advertised Oh around
that corner lady well around that corner
thank you have came in with the milkman
what's your name any any wonder bottom
here address now that's different for
28,000 Ian for 25 now how do I live in
the city well I was born down by the
gas house mind waiting a month please
here's $10 fee of trouble I'll call you when
I need you how do you do mr. slivers how do
I came in to see about this advertisement
oh you won't do that advertisement is for
females only an oversight oh well
I'd still like to see mr. Darnell
anyway well you can't instructions are
the mr. Darnell is available only today
the applicants ladies ladies Oh maybe
I'm wrong you are definitely Thanks
and what is your name please just call me
Mary Jones no he would rather not give you
a real name I don't know what this position
is but I wanted so I'd rather not be known
that's very smart what's your address may I
answer that when I know what you want me to
do well certainly how long have you lived
in the city about two weeks you know with
your parents no they're both dead I see what
you do have friends here no question Robert oh
this is miss Duncan uh Mary Jill yeah where
were you born miss Charles in a small town
in the Middle West you married a singer I've
never been married oh why do you want to sell
your life because I need money how much
do you need $20,000 it's a lot of money
what do you intend to do with it
I want it for my brother does he
live with you yes what does he do he's an artist I
suppose you want this money to further
him and his career yes does he know
you're doing this no how are you going to
explain your sudden wealth I can time it
came from an uncle in South America won't
he see through a bed my brother is blind
Miss Jones has an interesting background very
interesting yes I agree with you darling Miss
Jones after I've explained the details of
this proposition if you're still willing
to go through with it I'd like to give
you a cash advance in evidence of good
faith and the rest oh that will be paid to
whomever you named after you're dead after
I'm dead well yes the advisement
said we were buying your life yes
I know but you make it sound as though
I were dead already you are practically
I forgive it well say did you get that job in
there why should my affairs interest you well
perhaps it's just because I'm a well-bred
young man looking for my daily good deed I
thought well-bred young men were taught to mind
their own business nothing there as big as I am
but we'll say maybe I also introduced myself my
name is Breen Mordecai bring here here's my card
Mulligan's good for one meal corner no no no
I'm sorry my mistake yeah Moe glass pawnbroker
Oh again yeah here's the right one Mordecai
Breen editor and publisher the friend in need
was it your newspaper that carried the ad I'll
buy your life yeah that's why I'm here what
do you mean well it's customary for all good
newspapers to investigate your advertisers now
I have a hunch there's something wrong with that
set up in there you have a hunch it oh no wait I
I don't mean to pry into your business but won't
you please keep my card and if ever you really
need a friend with you will you promise to look me
up all right I promise Thanks hey now don't forget
waiting for the thumbs of the head in the day
by the moonlight
beautiful Raymer clean up my song list
while I Woo thee life's busy throng
beautiful Oh
hello sis like my song how'd you know I was home
a sixth sense I guess the blessing of the blind
now you're crying even though I can't see you I
can feel it fine ale why because I can't forget
it was my fault you went blood won't you please
smile just once for my sake sit there that's
better I like you so much better when you smile
I was worried about you today worried why I don't
know just Restless I guess I had a strange
feeling something was happening to you Phil
something happened to me today something wonderful
for both of us such as what for instance such as
I getting a big sum of money enough for you to go
the Lorentz Institute and have that eye operation
we've talked about so often then you can paint
again you see the trees and the flowers and the
blue sky in a few years people from all over
the world will visit some great Museum go on
sis I can see them now pointing to one of your
pictures I can hear them say there's a landscape
by Philip Laden as blind as I am sis I can see
that just the way your words have painted it
for me but suppose we do have the money what
if the operation isn't a success suppose it's
all hopeless what then it must be a success
it's got to be even if it isn't there'll be
enough money to take care of you for the rest of
your life what is it what's this all about Dale
still you remember Uncle John who went to Brazil
yes he died there a year ago well they're just
found his will he left us some money he did
how much $20,000 the lawyer advanced me mm I
have to go to South America to collect the rest
of it $18,000 $18,000 yes you're going to the
fern Haven rest home I made the arrangements
and have you prepared for your operation you
won't be here then while I'm going through
with it I can't fill the law requires that
I be there to collect the money there's a boat
sailing tomorrow night will you be gone for long
I said will you be gone for long I don't know I'm
going to miss you sis I'll miss you Phil maybe
it's all for the best I know it's all for the best
I rolled and play something now I get supper ready
hello mr. hammer hello Green there aren't any
needy cases being let out of jail to thee well
that isn't exactly why I came you you see you
there's an advertisement in my newspaper that
I I thought might interest you I haven't time
for any advertisements now Breen I'm working on
an important murder well perhaps I can help you
what kind of a murder is it oh go away what kind
there's only one kind people get killed oh yes
of course I hadn't thought of that hey who was
it that party girl who was found dead outside
the soccer club all I've got her a couple of
bullets this piece off a woman's heel and a pearl
I dropped on the floor found on the scene of the
crime I don't suppose you ever heard of pearls
you weaken with oysters this one's worth about
$500 expensive meal oh yeah thanks I know that
belongs to Ruth's family there was murdered it
don't and neither does this piece of leather off
a woman's heel no no the pearls worth a look you
amateur sleuth don't you think I thought of that
my men have grown bunions traipsing that trinket
around no juror recognizes it one man said he
was positive it was a foreign rigor majiggy oh
that's too bad but don't think I'm stymied to
make an arrest anyway yes well mr. hammer about
this ad here I look Breen I know you do a lot of
good finding people work in homes but I can't be
bothered right now please do me a favor just
this once and go away all right all right I'll
go away hey look hammer it was a little say hammer
with Joe Thompson gets out of prison than either
give me the suit huh what'd you say I said when
you give this suit to Joe Thompson lately it'll
make him happy and give him a fresh start sure
sure you know there's Darnell and put in this
ad not personally ain't he the orchestra leader
at the club Sirocco yeah I believe he is that's
him now there's a setup I can't understand what
do you mean Darnell engaged to a rich girl like
Valencia Duncan she's madly in love with him yet
he chases around with other Dame's it's a screwy
world my friend yeah I guess you're right
what do you think there's anything to that
n-no no no thanks just the same green oh don't
mention it and you won't forget Thompson with
it no no aah nice little Suzie I don't know
what I'd do without butter Susan died Susie
no my name is Mary oh well I was looking for
Suzie and I'm looking for mr. Breen oh well you
wait here just a minute see he's a pretty busy
man but I see if you'll grant you an interview
mr. bean what is it happy Mary
wants to see you Mary Mary who
well I uh I know you forgot to answer
all right tell her to come in yes sir
mr. brain Oh see ya
you didn't expect to see me so soon did you well
if I may be frank I didn't but but I'm delighted
my name is John Jones Mary Jones I'm delighted
to meet you Miss Jones won't you sit down I I'm
here to take advantage of that offer of help
well that offer still homes but I'm wondering
wondering whether I can trust you why how can you
say such a thing sitting there looking straight in
my eyes shining like diamonds with honesty are
you sure it's honesty that's making them shine
perhaps we better start all over again exactly
what I need is an executor I'm willing to pay
the fee Oh why do people always start meetings
like this talking about money why don't they
start with friendship or something I don't we got
of a had a friend a real friend you got one now
thank you my request is rather strange after I've
explained it I want you to tell me honestly where
do you care to undertake it or not well I want
to take anything that's honest and oh in your
case I I might even stretch a point your part is
perfectly honest I have here two envelopes this
small one is addressed to you when you receive
$18,000 you are to open it yeah won't that be
after I'm dead oh come now you're to attack of
a person to start jumping off bridges just let
her hear I let me continue in this you will find
the name and address of the man to whom you are
to give the money is that clear perfectly after
you've shuffled off this mortal coil the insurance
company or somebody well-well delivered to me
eighteen thousand dollars which I am to deliver
two gentlemen name an address in this envelope
that's right after give him the money you're to
burn this letter unopened yes but but I don't
get the money they refuse to pay then you're to
open this the two story of Mary Jones say yeah
I'll bet that's interesting it is if you don't
receive the money open it read it and see that
justice is done ha ha ha ha ha say what kind
of funny business is this if you don't care to do
this mom oh now wait a minute wait a minute don't
get on a high horse I I mean no offense it's just
a peculiar request that's all I suppose it is but
it's the only way I can do it why don't you tell
me the whole story I can't I wish I could all I
can do is trust you well don't worry about that
if I say I'll do a thing I'll do it you're sure
you understand yes if I get money I delivered
the man addressing this envelope if I don't get
money I open up the big arm up and fight for
justice and Mary Jones and you'll do it I will
on one condition that you'll have dinner with
me oh I can't well hell no dinner no executor
but I'm willing to pay the fee my fee for legal
services is always 25 cents but I'm afraid that
well in that this case I'll have to ask for an
additional retainer one dinner I guess it won't
hurt me to have one last fling I'll pay the
fee all right well like all for it you can't
where can I meet you clubs Rocco Webster Rocco yes
it's a date ten o'clock oh I hadn't thought of it
before this may put you in considerable danger oh
forget it I will if you do this for me fairly and
honestly I'll owe you more than you'll ever know
I know I rest easier with you on my side Thanks
sweet you look gorgeous thank you right
Timmy yeah I thought we could go to the
sit over to candidate marvelous have
some coffee before we go listen yes oh
yes all right time to come up please oh is it
lieutenant hammer he's over those firmly case
come in Lantana come in oh you know miss Valencia
Duncan yes I've seen her at the soccer club Oh
am i intruding no not at all we're just leaving
for the club yeah a cup of coffee I know Thanks
I wanted to ask you about this little paper
you did you advertised to buy somebody's life
well yes that's my ad all right detective stories
perhaps you read some of them yeah very good too
well they haven't been lately you see I haven't
out of good idea so I decided to advertise and
get some life stories of real people that's all
look that's an idea maybe I could get some help
like that to solve some of my murder keys why
don't you advertise maybe a will have a cigar
today no thanks Darnell you're a very versatile
man you write books and you'll even orchestra
have you ever been on the stage I'm only an
amateur plays ever been a female impersonator
you'll see the Higgins kids in those clothes
you said over for did they fit like a big ballin
ready could I put something in your safe sure
come on into my office what you're putting in a
big bankroll now over suddenly this is valuable
letter I I don't want to lose say no more about
a college safe better put your moniker on this
so you can get it back location nothing happens
to me that's right Danny I haven't thought of
that just to make things look a little bit more
businesslike do you mind giving me receipt
sure always give a receipt that's my model
received from nordica three one big envelope very
personal famous Oh Grady thanks a million now how
about a nice table for just you or give you mine
nothing's too good for my friends that's my motto
no I think I'd like this one's ready Sabrina I
want you to meet our orchestra leader mr. Darnell
shake hands with one of my best friends Darnell
did you say yeah it's Albert Darnell about the
famous writer of mystery stories I'm afraid I'll
have to plead guilty you know I tried to meet you
once before when you put an ad in my paper oh yes
yes anything to get material one of my books well
that's how I was that was a clever idea well
won't you join me in the drink whenever while
I work thanks just the same that's right never
mix liquor with labor that's my motto Wow see you
later got to keep the show moving now see that man
gives you the best of us Thank You Trevi and now
ladies and gentlemen I give you mr. Lensky Duncan
who recently made her debut as our feature artist
in the tank to the I'm a team Dora
incidentally are you single and
incidentally I can't I don't hate to darkness Oh
or read a book and when you make a date
I must record all the facts of your life
and incidentally to useful and are you
okay can you easily take a job incidentally
I must record all the cast of your life comes way
what
into this night maybe we never forget it sure
I never will and I'm sure I'll never want
I wish I knew whoever thing that what
happened in that interview with mr.
Darnell maybe you will someday
my interview with mr. Darnell
we have never proved anything but a success
why did she come here I don't know darling I'm
going to find out what sweetheart
will you stop worrying about me
it's a beautiful place that you have you're like
yes did you know what the pearls were missing sir
did I have to get another one to replace it have
you heard that bracelet long about three years
any more questions mr. Breen you're hoping
I will be permitted to buy you another pearl
me
idiot must put up here
that water does McCarty yo Tony back outta me
anything better
well why did it keep staring at me like
this do some room for improvement yes
such a such as being just a little bit
more frank with me I'd like to know more
about Mary Jones that's all written
in the letter I gave it is afternoon
- gnarly Jones success
how did I get any onion I'm very
sorry I don't seem to be able to
hold anything tonight not even here at ease
are you sure there's nothing more you want
to tell me about yourself Muhsin question
me nothing wine continue over you permit me
to ask you just one more question something
I forgot when you were in my off what
did you well I know when Mary Jones is
is dead you'll know all right the whole
city will know when Mary Jones is dead
party you can expect these poems on wire
he's a friend of ours how are you feel
everything's fine I'm perfectly comfortable
oh that's wonderful I'm on my way to the steamer
now promise me you won't worry I promise and be
sure you don't worry on my account thanks for
all you've done for me sips envoy eyes goodbye
are you doing here I came to see you who saved
me that's right but for if you're the name of
the man to whom you were to pay the rest of the
money is it mr. Breen gentlemen at my table did
you tell him anything I gave mr. Breen a sealed
envelope in which is written the entire story
you paying the money is agreed that letter will be
destroyed if you don't well use your own judgment
please get message to the gentleman sitting at mr.
Grady's table that I've been called away suddenly
take me to the police station do you see what
I saw looks like the thing
that rubbed out root family
you recognize any of the policemen yeah they
look like they're from Central
Station we better phone Bocchini
jet tech girl says the lady who was with you
just left in the police cars please yeah in
Central Station oh my to be sure the same
to read by somebody I don't know what you
mean by that I'm simply here to confess to the
murder of Ruth Parmalee why haven't you given
yourself up before because I thought I could
get away with it and my conscience bothered me
I killed her I tell you if you want any more
proof here's the gun that fired the shots
okay lady you asked for it lock her up Mac and
Ella matron when she searches her to bring that
bracelet and her slippers back here to me where
are you damn minute what's up I want to ask this
girl a few questions are you her lawyer yes you
know she's just confessed to a murder I don't care
what she's confessed she's innocent and I know it
and what's more I'm going to prove it what did you
say your name was Mary Jones do you know this man
Miss Jones no I never saw him before in my life
that's good enough for me Hagar way
Mac look herobrine I like you but when
it comes to butting in on the case like
this all bets between us are all hammer
I'm going to help that girl I want to
see her alone not a chance until I talk
with the chief nothing you can do what all
right I'll go home but I won't forget it
hey hammer wait a minute wait a minute what do
you mean by busting in here like this what do you
think the station is a joint yeah say that line
of talk for somebody that scares easier and I do
you know better than that what do you want here
little wild like know one of your cars picked up
a girl over the club Scirocco and brought her
here so on so what I want to see her oh you're
running the police department now are you might
be a good idea if I did I want to see that Dame
maybe that could be arranged if you have a good
reason reason supposing my two boys here saw a
shoe truth formerly that's a pretty good reason in
it it's perfect that's all I need an eyewitness to
the crime but low camera you need a motive to to
make it perfect and don't forget that well maybe
I'm getting lucky all of a sudden a motive liable
to jump up from any place any minute now come on
bring it up to the bars I want to see
her clothes step up closer Miss Jones
this gentleman wants to see if he can
identify you he's a little nearsighted
say you're the one honey you did it what
do you mean why did you kill my Ruth kill
who why did you kill Ruth finally because
I was jealous jealous of what she tried to
take my sweetheart look at me you're lying my
Ruth never wanted anybody but me what CD you
heard what she said hammer there's your motive
she kills for jealousy jealous of my remarry
take a good look make sure you sure this is a
girl to rub my roots out on the parking lot of the
Sirocco Club cure that's the girl satisfied mr.
hammer perfectly Puccini you did a swell job yeah
can you see that you two a swell job - meaning
what I mean this you see the she pays for what she
did and don't you fail hammer but if you do I'll
see the she pays me but sheedy life for a life
we find the defendant Mary Jones
guilty of murder in the first degree
oh great oh man we're ready oh he's going done
yes it's a mighty place poker well I don't know
where he's playing tonight listen Matt I get a
pretty a letter to put in the safe now gives us
receipt for time I'd like to get it oh you're
out of luck I can't give it to you Greg lot too
safe I am got the combination expect them back
tonight not when he plays poker would you mind
telling Darnell I'd like to see him in here
he seems to be your bad luck day Darnell's
left with the first fiddle took over what will
you talk about if you give me a ring when it
comes in tomorrow I'll leave a note on a desk
man boy thanks pal thank you hello Jenny yeah
visit me porcini did you get that letter not yet
but don't worry about it I will you better hurry
up my clients getting restless who's your client
never mind about that my clients giving me $3,000
to buy read letter but I want you to get hurt
and we'll split the 3 grand Oh 5050 huh well if
Puccini gets his share that's all right huh okay
soon as you get that letter give me a ring yeah
oh it's always bring about it's a tough monk in
your office but to what I'm thinking Jerusalem I
know I'm from away back something like your
step what's he doing in my private office I
told him to wait out here What did he say scram
Wow Oh your name green it is I don't like people
to put their feet on my desk I like my company
take your feet off my desk Oh tough guy huh well
let me change I'll get you for this forget the
way you're doing here no any want to check it
and the boss wants to talk to you who's the
boss but Jeannie Jeannie don't don't go mr.
Brean vicini he dangers dangerous yeah he's
from our neighborhood he's bad what does he
want to see me for chin he wants to talk
to you about something important a letter
a letter what letter I ain't saying anymore
all right where is this Puccini I got a car
wait okay just around the corner okay I'll
go you stay here happy I'm expecting a call
from Grady yes Tom to leave word where I can
get in touch with him later all right come on
he's bad mr. Breen I'm telling you changes
this is mr. Breen boss he bumped my head against
the wall and he took my gun away from me I took
it away from him because he's too impulsive well
that's nice work young fella but that's a little
dangerous when Puccini wants to see a man he
wants to see him and besides it ain't good
policy to beat up on one of my boys you catch
just who are you mr. Puccini there is only one
booty knee that's me the greatest builder
of concrete blocks in the whole world no
but I don't want any concrete blocks and you
might sometime you know what know what inside
I'm soft everything is beautiful in here and when
somebody don't do what I want then I'm hard just
like my concrete catch no I don't catch look mr.
brain one word from Puccini and you could be cut
up into small pieces and put into my concrete
building blocks and then when I pass the big
building there's a name on it the brain building
I say to myself who's holding that building up
nobody but you my friend you understand I want
that letter why don't you dictate all this to a
secretary in send it to me special delivery
I Cali I like you well as a matter of fact
marring your suggestion of chopping up people
for building material right I like you too
but Genie is quick he hates or he likes just like
that ha ha my friend che can why not now we are
friends that's what I say mr. brain you and me
should be in business together well perhaps we
will be someday who can tell that's the way I
like to do things quick like that's the way I
like to do it too lonely quicker put out guards
are worried you're fools they don't understand
friendship but you do mr. Brady I'm not sure I
understand what the best of friends until you
get your hands on that letter I knew it you're
a smart man mr. Brady or Sabatini as friends a
friend how much were you offered for that letter
three thousand dollars are you sad hmm I thought
you were smart I honestly did well you lean
don't you realize that if somebody offered
you $3,000 for that letter it's worth a lot more
money don't you catch oh yeah I catch but Genie
ask for more money and then when they bid high
enough you give me the letter than we split my
well now that we're gonna be friends for life
lets you and me come clean you know like one
guy to another that suits me fine now we get
down to business you've got the letter in your
pocket I know just to prove to the others my
heart's in the right place yeah there's all
my cards on the table hi Joey he's my friend
I trusted with my life but first him anyway
don't forget familiar
mother you say good for one meal corner of
eights and Hogan's Alley golly that reminds
me I'd like there's something eat myself
how about you mr. gray Thanks well I are
you satisfied I don't have the letter on
me perfectly satisfied my friend perfectly
satisfied you can go now you'll be hearing from
Puccini again okay sure sure so long my pal
can't you see you've got to tell me the truth
I've told you all you need to know who is bikini
I don't know I never saw him until his men
identified me as the killer of Ruth's prom
Leigh Wow you didn't kill her I know you didn't
matter who identified you a jury will think so
I'm not going to let you go up before a jury
not if I can help it are you gonna stop it
I'm going to read that letter no no you can't
you promised you mustn't do that I believe that
letter contains the truth and if you won't
tell me the letter will if you opened that
letter before the $18,000 is paid I'll hate you
do you understand all hate you that letters all
that stands between us and happiness brother open
that letter right now no wait a minute let me play
you certainly left in a hurry last night anything
wrong oh nothing much just a little personal issue
that's all yeah I get it mind your own business
that's my model your letter isn't here Breen it
isn't that well ordered I mean it's gotta be
there on the level it was here last night when
I left say are you kidding me Denny no what does
anybody else know the combination of that safe
way yes Darnell he's a silent partner in this
place Darnell Oh maybe he took it by mistake
check with him will you Denny yeah sure give and
take that's my model how did you any idea who
could have stolen that letter only two men nor the
combination of that safe Grady and I now got no
now don't you see you've got to tell me the
truth I must know why you've done all this
won't you please tell me wait give me kind of
thinking don't you real has you been tricked but
somebody's double-crossing him without that letter
you'll never get the money you're just sacrificing
your life for nothing with that letter missing
you haven't got a chance hey sir I'm beginning
to what is 10 and you didn't kill Ruth Parmalee
did you tell me did you know know what I knew
you didn't cuz why did you make that confession
because I needed money I needed it desperately for
an operation on my brother's eyes he's blind it's
my fault even though they may be operating on it
I wanted for that and to take care of them in case
the operation wasn't a success now you understand
I must ask you a few more questions just one
or two finance of the module yes I'll try your
name isn't Mary Jones is it no they are laden
tell-tale did to Darnell and Valencia doesn't
give you those clothes you wore at the club
Soraka yes and slippers and the bracelet
and the gun yes and that letter you asked me to
destroy contain it the two facts of this case I
need to know hello who did you say the gentleman
says his name is breeding Mordecai breehn breehn
send him up immediately you may go upstairs mr.
Breen apartment 12 812 a 12-8 thanks very much
how do you do miss Duncan my name is Puccini
oh yeah yes you're surprised to see me well the
clerk said it was mr. breem yes I know I told
him that night I thought if I tell him my own
name you might be out of something may I come in
of course thank you well this is a nice place you
have here thank you it's mr. Dale's apartment
oh I see do you mind if I sit down no go ahead
you know miss Duncan it it's good to sit down
again I've been walking walking yes I took a long
walk up a long hill I just paid Ruth a visit you
mean music family yes there's only one girl in the
world for me and that's Ruth hmm you'll excuse
me miss Duncan if I act like a crybaby I think
you will excuse me won't you yes of course miss
Duncan sit down here I I want to say something to
you sit right over here just a minute please I'd
rather you'd sit here beside me if you don't mind
here
these are for me all for
you i I picked them myself
Thanks I don't quite know how else to
say uh-huh there isn't anything else
to say but one thing and this isn't the
time to say it you know miss Duncan the
grass is nice and green up there on the
hill where I picked those flowers off a
Ruth's grave you know I planted to myself
where Ruth is sleeping pretty ain't they
yeah take those things back you don't like flowers
well that's too bad you better get out of here
before I call the police call the police if you
do call the police I'll show them this letter that
Mary Jones wrote and gave to my friend mr. Brean
I don't know what you mean oh yes you do now you
get this you're going with me are we going we're
going for a little ride you and me a little ride
property of Mordecai breathe yeah there's a
gentleman outside to see you says his name
is Darnell oh yes I've been expecting him tell
him to come in okay - I'm happy see that were
not disturbed well he's here with you sure
boss now you a mouse I'll stare come ahead
mr. Darnell are you sent for me mr. Breen hello
Darnell yes I did say you know a short time ago
a young lady left a letter with me and her
name was Mary Jones have you ever heard of
her oh yes I bought the story of her life
to put one of my novels and you agreed to
pay her $18,000 for that story am i right
approximately I agreed to pay the eighteen
thousand only after she'd fulfilled certain
contractual obligations you mean after she
gone to the electric chair won't you sit down
Thank You Darnell for purely private reasons I
feel I no longer want to keep that letter in my
possession why not well my good judgment tells
me not to and and yet say I want to fulfill my
agreement with Miss Jones well if I could be of
any service mr. beam I'd be only too happy you
can be of service haha by paying me the $18,000
and you'll turn the letter over to me unopened
immediately I will you know I rather imagine
from your telephone call that something
like this would occur so I came prepared
would you mind giving me a receipt for
this no not at all well simply right well
dated first receipt of Mordecai Breen one
large envelope and contents sealed sealed
left in his possession by Mary Jones
Sam hey and there you are thank you
but there's nothing in him a blank paper
what is this a double-cross yes just as you
double-cross Mary Jones into the confession
of a murder that she never committed I don't
know what you're talking about maybe you don't
but I do do what for your information
Puccini brought your girlfriend Valencia
Duncan to the station a while ago without
any trouble on my part she told the whole
story what story the story of how she shot
Ruth's family because she was jealous and
brother whether you know it or not you're going
to be leading the band at state prison come on
for the phone no no for the lady
daddy Barney I was afraid of that
I sure wish Eppie was back on the job
I'm getting solid a horse all over my
body from London this fresh doesn't happy
work here anymore no I got him a job with
a city concrete inspector there how's that
mr. Bochy need they fill it you read this I
forgot my glasses the friend in need is
happy to announce the coming wedding of
its editor mr. Mordechai Breen to miss Dale
Laden at the little church around the corner